[Music]
speaking firstly i am from boston and uh
i'm a big uh thank you
thank you six of you uh
i'm a huge patriots fan but i i just
want to take one second here at the top
of the show to congratulate the new york
giants on their super bowl victory i
think that's i think that's the right
thing to do
i mean
sure you're you're being nice about it
now
okay what what was that i mean what what
are you talking about andy we were
furious at the super bowl party last
night
no it was not i was very nice i was very
calm no you were furious and it was
embarrassing
i don't think so andy as i remember it i
was very gracious very
very gracious
[Music]
and it's over
the crowd is on its feet
we'll be right back
i'm sorry conan you must be pretty
disappointed
on the contrary old friend
it's just a game and that's the way it
goes sometimes i say a toast
a toast to the new york giants
wow you sure are gracious in defeat
yes i am andy richter yes i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pretty much how i remember it
that's total bs
why don't you why don't you tell them
how it really happened
oh yeah andy what really happened
[Music]
and it's over
the crowd is on its feet
we'll be right
back no
no
it can't be over
it's over conan
get out of here
out of this house everybody party's over
wait a minute this is my house i don't
care
i looked forward to this
for months
months and it was over too quickly
but it's not over i mean it's only
halftime and new england's ahead
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about madonna's halftime show
it's over
i love you madge
i love you
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay then
it was a hell of a party we're still
wearing the same clothes
[Laughter]
yes